they should do a modern-day one with
just a regular HP yeah we're like five
minutes
Kinkos everybody grab them ready grab
printer hello reject nation its Greg
Alba here and I'm John Humphrey today
we're gonna talk about Steven Spielberg
goes to the post before we go into
opinions and whatnot wanted to tell you
guys we're going to switch up our review
style a little bit just to give us some
distinction amongst the crowd and go
back to our roots we're gonna have our
little pros and cons list we used to do
this thing called reasons to see reasons
not to see so we're gonna break it down
like that a little different though not
exactly like how we did it in the old
days also got to give a shout out today
is awesome sponsor the Stardust app
people were almost at 4,000 followers
thank you guys so much for following us
John and I have been catching up on a
lot of awards movies lately the post
being one of them so we've been putting
up all our Stardust reviews over there
it's an app that allows you do 30-second
reactions or reviews for any film TV
show or trailer a lot of your favorite
youtubers are definitely using this app
right now but if we're the first wants
to tell you download the app and follow
us first you got it and if you like us
more than whoever told you first
follow us first as well just for a
second I wanted to taste it alright the
post so before we go into our list
I'm gonna tell you guys what the plot is
of this movie oohs were here from I um
DB with some trailer footage over it a
cover up that span four u.s. presidents
pushed the country's first female
newspaper publisher and a hard-driving
editor join an unprecedented battle
against journalists and government all
right here we go
first reason to see this movie story and
directing yeah it's good second reason
also good here's the bullet points list
of why you should go
mathematical score of the block when
this movie started I kind of forgot what
the trailer told me this movie was about
I remember when I saw the trailer it hit
me as an odd thing because I started
watching the CNN documentary about the
sixties at Tom Hanks produced and the
first their second episode had a lot to
do with the importance of journalism and
then I'm watching this movie and it's
all about the importance of journalism
in the 60s I'm like I saw a whole
produced Tom Hanks episode about the
seventies ya know sixties spanning but
this is the movie takes place in the
early seventies this movie shows you
just how valuable journalism is and or
was at least and the significance of it
how important was to free the press and
you see how this event was so monumental
in aiding the disbelief and lack of
trust that we have in the American
government and we're just doing it all
over it you don't like it do you watch
it and it is so parallel oh yeah yes
rewrite repeat yeah so cool yeah it's a
powerful story and an important one and
a very relevant one too it's not as much
in my face as I was expecting it to be
you know Meryl Streep's character being
the first female publisher so when she
walks into that boardroom then there's a
whole bunch of men there exploring that
story in and of itself is just
interesting to see because it was also a
story of what the newspaper was
struggling with at the time
well yeah you joined the newspaper and
right before they're about to go public
they're making a big shift yeah not at
all the time to be caught up an intense
legal battle with the government I don't
know how accurate every detail wasn't
the story but I thought it was a really
smart approach to take it from we're
rooting for these characters we see
these Tom Hanks and Meryl Streep are
good people down on their luck lately
the newspapers failing and you really
want them to succeed
and they also have a strong motivating
reason now to do even better it's
actually like a real tense movie there
are scenes of dialogue that are so well
done you're just on edge waiting for the
end of the conversation oh yeah and I
mean it comes from multiple angles
because you've got the initial debate of
just taking the paper in the commercial
what's gonna sell direction versus
what's it for direction yeah
then you have the whole onset of all the
legal circumstances stuff and there's so
much in this movie that's just about the
debate of philosophy this is a bunch of
different characters over the span of a
situation it's rolling down their
philosophy and making tense choice yes
you know and our two main character know
the powerful people
yeah they rub shoulders with the the
elites and stuff this movie they
uncovered in this 7,000 page document
and it's all this big debate on whether
or not they should or shouldn't publish
this this is like damning Topsy out
information that a government is banning
us from having free press you don't have
the right to this info necessarily
however this proves that they're
directly lying yes you know what do you
do I thought was great it's a monumental
and important story
I remember they touched on that in the
CNN documentary but not explore to this
level of death where you see our main
characters know some of the people
involved in this scandal that America
has been covering up so you see their
own personal conflict with it cuz they
don't want to destroy their friendships
they don't want to ruin the lives of
people they've loved for years which is
another really relevant thing about this
movie even outside of like politics and
the news just like those choices we all
have to make now confronting the issues
we are in society about what happens
when our friends do bad things yeah what
do we do in the face of that and the
script is really well done I think it's
interesting when spielberg does these
types of dramas because it's bill berg
who loves to shoot in the master shop
yeah and when you see that in his big
movies that's so cool and then when you
see that in his smaller films like this
got a patent you really got to focus
because it's like listening to an aaron
sorkin script that doesn't cut anybody
the first time you see Tom Hanks and
Meryl Streep on screen together is so
awesome like it's these two actors and
their first scene it's like in a few
minutes of them talking the camera
hasn't cut in this one master shot I
respect that Spielberg lets the audience
choose where to pay attention because
there's a lot going on the background
he's really establishing the environment
feels they lived in that way yeah so
sometimes the pace can feel a little bit
off to me and there's some really cool
shots and some really striking visuals
in here but they're also occasionally
moments where I'm like is he just kind
of showing off and doing something cool
at
doesn't really feel necessary but
overall by the time this movie starts
really picking up and gets really
intense you're like oh this is why spill
where he is the master filmmaker that he
is because this picture because I
thought for the most part it was really
creatively shot it was pretty tense all
the things they're supposed to make you
feel triumphant worked for the most part
yeah yeah I was surprised at how much I
was caught up in it and how much I was
yelling and how thrilling I thought it
was and I appreciated all that attention
to letting these characters with good
inclinations make the choices that lead
them to becoming better people yeah and
making really strong as dance choices
yeah yeah yeah it's like you mean
there's so many times were like oh it's
cool when you can do that with a movie
were all that's really at stake is just
information you know which is huge but
at the same time it's not people getting
hacked up the prologue to caught me
because I didn't realize we were gonna
start in the war yeah and like have a
few minutes of like Steven Spielberg war
movie on top of the political thriller
the 13th Vil he did Saving Private Ryan
yeah but it's still pretty star yeah and
it's all muddy and gross and not to
mention the attention they pay to the
actual process of printing in this movie
there are there's sequences where they
show you the machinery that's some cool
spill bird shots right there yeah yeah
cool but also perfectly merited by the
movie because you know you realize the
importance and also just how much work
when it is that like the you see people
like assembling the actual lines yeah
type sets it's cool there's more that
cuz I'm like I had no idea that's a
little science lesson like the way it's
done it's like I'm a can I get a fresh
newspaper yeah but this movie so much
about what the article means and what
the story is that there's an intensity
to the words being printed yeah yeah
yeah they feel that much more tangible
and seeing hands assemble that you
really get the sense for the time yeah
you know and and with a movie that's all
about deadlines and when it comes time
to print are we gonna have something
yeah it really drives that point home
because they have to print it yeah yeah
yeah good use of inserts yeah so reason
to see number two is the lead actors
Meryl Streep and Tom
Hank's boy oh boy I mean they first did
this revealing Shaw we're about to see
Tom Hanks for the first time I said out
loud like this crazy Tom Hanks and Meryl
Streep oh my god really looking forward
to seeing these guys act together if so
trend there are so many scenes with them
together each time they're together in a
scene it is evolving their relationship
is evolving their dynamics I like how it
wasn't a romantic interplay what solo no
no they're just going back and forth me
yeah they're just friends who respect
each other we have a very different
point of views on how to handle things
yeah the way they butt heads and the way
they find agreements here and there is
so well executed they have some of the
best moments in the movie Meryl Streep
kills it aw dude it was occasionally I
am the guy who's like she's a little
over it like I this is an amazing
amazing actress but then there are times
I'm like she doesn't need to get
nominated for anything there's times
where you've heard enough praises that
you go into a movie and you're like she
really is a great as they say yeah then
within a few minutes oh man such poison
such effortless she just feels surreal
in this I'd like you when Meryl Streep
plays a little bit more of the shy
nervous insecure type of character her
and like a Devil Wears Prada is great
but this this ain't that woman even
though she's the first female publisher
there's a lot at stake in her business
and personal life when she starts off
it's a journey of her growing to being
someone powerful self empowered and
confident and what's interesting about
the movie is the first half cuts back
and forth during a lot of different
people they enter kind of like there's
the real lead of this movie yeah the
leads sort of emerged which i think is a
nice thing yeah that's how these
situations always happen kind of a swirl
at the bottom then it starts to climb
you know up through the different people
that take the torch and it's cool seeing
Tom Hanks in this role - you know we're
all used to Tom Hanks the nice guy I
mean exactly
the nice guy in this movie if anything
he's the ruthless one he's the one he
will just tell me how I determine closer
to the lines of what's that you're not
crying in baseball
movie was a league of their own yeah
it's more like that guy yeah I think
he's very no BS yeah knows the way and
he's gonna pursue it no matter what both
are very inspiring characters I don't
know how accurate they were portrayed
but from imagining these are real human
beings it was inspiring to know the
journey is these two went on even times
we were like are you sure about this Tom
Hanks but as the film keeps going you do
side with him more and the
decision-making because at the end of
day Meryl Streep is the head of all this
and she comes down to the top decisions
of how anything will go there's one
scene where she has to make a huge
decision that had John and I really just
on Julia and it's really her acting and
great directive from Spielberg panning
in on her we're just making a decision
thinking yeah and playing up the tension
of that it just feel like that when
you're in a situation like that we got
multiple people who all need a huge
answer from you this second and so much
of this movie is in the back-and-forth
between Tom Hanks and and Meryl Streep
they make this great yin-yang because
those two personalities come together
and inform each other I love that their
advisors to each other like they take
notes from each other and when she calls
him out he takes that into consideration
and vice versa and you see how if it
wasn't right group of people this might
not happen that's a powerful thing about
the movie and their performances you
know because they sell them 100 percent
reason to see number three Bob Odenkirk
has been but BD key and Big D Qian
I remember one thing when we did the
trailer reaction for this I remember
saying something along the lines of I
know he's barely in the trailer but I
bet you he's gonna be a standout
performer ah Bob Odenkirk looks like he
might be a bit of a scene stealer when
he's in front of the camera oh I feel
like he always is I remember saying that
because there's a lot of supporting
actors in this movie he's the main
supporting actor that you really get to
spend time with and I'm glad we did
because he is awesome in this movie when
he's on screen I'm not like can we get
back to Meryl Streep can we get back to
Tom Hanks like he has his own little
journey going on that is crucial that is
super important to the story yeah but he
also has so much life in this character
Bob Odenkirk is perfectly cast for this
specific type of character but he's a
lot more of the caring bob odenkirk yeah
he's still got his time did Bobby Hill
still be straightforward he'll still be
blunt he'll still tell it how it is
sometimes
now and again I also have some [ __ ]
remarks here and there but for the most
part he's the guy who you know is
fighting for the writing and it's cool
to see Bob Odenkirk in this role and he
has so many layers in this movie there
are times where he's funny
there are times his dramatic weight has
really felt I really admired that he got
the opportunity to be in a Spielberg
film and have such a standout role oh
dude he can he can jump into anybody's
world now and yeah sort of proven that
and yeah he's great reason the scene
number four the supporting cast there
are a lot of great supporting players in
this movie besides Bob Odenkirk I mean a
lot of people who pop up that I wasn't
expecting there's like David Cross is in
this Bradley Whitford Bruce Greenwood
Jesse Plemons Jesse Plemons very quickly
bad as well yes yes I think I think you
might have gained that for Fargo or
something because I've never lost it
right into the post all my characters
mileage I forget creepy skinny tah
chubby likable guy they all show up and
pretty much do the things that they're
known to be good at Bradley Whitford
does yes you know smartass the worst of
us you know a lot of heavy dialogue
fast-talking bruce greenwood tough nice
guy little suspicious Jesse Plemons had
a had a late supporting role in this
film and I thought he was a really good
addition to I like when guys I'm used to
seeing playing like creepy to be like oh
you didn't necessarily have to take this
but you're bringing something to it I
know like you showed up and gave this a
shot in the arm carry it through to the
next step Matthew Rice's in this movie
and he's a very important character yeah
he's the one who's responsible for
providing all these documentation and he
was a really motivating character for me
in this film too this is the first time
I've been really aware of him but he did
a great job for the most part there's
the supporting cast is all pretty solid
and it's great to see a large and samba
love character isn't her and even
African guy from Silicon Valley in the
office Zack would
he pretty much share it just what Zach
woods would do but in a serious for me
to score by the composer Spielberg
always works with Danny else John
Williams another great John Williams
score I feel like when you think of the
John Williams scores you think of the
great adventurous pictures Star Wars the
Indiana's the ETS whatever this movie is
just a tension based political thriller
the car there's still a lot of the job
where like when I was listening to it I
remember asking John is this John
Williams's I never I think he's always
this bougatsa but I just wasn't a
hundred percent sure there's definitely
nuances to the music that are very
William signature he stretches a little
bit early on there were times in there
in the first half of the movie I wasn't
certain if it was him there there are
also some times toward the Enron like as
Yahweh's a thousand percent really it
does aid in the tenseness of a lot of
the situations though it's perfectly
composed yeah yeah it always you know it
always matches the scenes in the pace
alright guys gonna move on to our cons
list yeah reason not to see number one
underutilized performances a lot of
people show up and not everybody gets as
much time as they like Alison Brie I
thought did a really good job with her
scenes she left an impact on me but I
did hope to see more and even worse I
thought was Sarah Paulson I was like oh
you're a terrific actress really just
there for one scene yeah yeah well it
wasn't like crucial that it may hurt
like she's in she's in like several
scenes for moments but then there's one
scene where you're like okay that's the
point of your character and she does it
really well it's just like I wish for
your time you've gotten more to do yeah
and same thing with like Michael
Stuhlbarg who's the head of the New York
Times here number one we like he does a
good job it's just every time he showed
up I thought oh that's right he's in
this I just think when you get these
really respectable known to be great
actors you should either utilize them
more or give the opportunity to a lesser
amount cuz then it gets distracting at
least a little bit cuz you're like oh is
that for that person back that much okay
we got enough famous people in here yeah
which is kind of a nitpick I guess you
know we can get over it but at the same
time you know you
you do wish that you know you know the
talent that they have you wish they got
this from me yeah reason not to see
number two ham-fisted finale moments in
order to explain this because there are
moments in here where it gets to the
messages themes that are like super
Spielberg yes and it took away some of
the realism for me there are very
specific moments and dialogue of how
it's being captured yes it's way too on
the nose for me we're gonna go do like a
minor spoilers here it's a true story so
we're not really spoiling anything for
you but if you want to skip some details
here you can hear you can skip to this
moment in the video for me it's as far
to I'll skip to this one if you haven't
seen the movie yet but here it is one
two three four five well Meryl Streep
dies in front of Tom Hanks as a kid yeah
yeah Wow okay so in this movie's
wrapping up there's like a very few
specific moments that's too much man too
much as I'm all for this age that we
have of strong female empowerment and I
knew this movie was gonna deal with that
especially when you see the plot of how
this movie is unfolding and who Meryl
Streep's character is and there's this
scene where she's going to court a girl
comes up to her who works for the
government
and pretty much says I want you to win
and that was fine that honestly was
totally fine because it was this big
rally going out sighs big protest I fell
free the press for their that was a good
moment yeah and I thought that that
should have been it and it would have
spoke enough volumes for me because I'm
like well she's a woman in the
government this probably represents a
lot of women right now this is a moment
happen first she's leaving the court and
his giant crowd of protesters and then
Meryl Streep's is walking down the steps
and she just happens to walk past this
one section of a crowd where there's no
man only woman and as she's walking
through the crowd they're all doing that
slow had turned her and it was just too
cheesy and I just didn't by the moment
it seemed like too movie like for me it
was pretty realistic for a lot of it you
know yeah that's where I start to
complain a little bit about those things
is when they start to
really shift the focus and they call
attention to themselves yeah it's like I
don't think it's a bad moment in and of
itself I just would have handled it
perhaps differently yeah or not again
ham-fisted it quite so much I don't like
it when I'm singing a crowd going I get
it yeah there are a lot of great
subtleties that play to that effect
and then to have the contrast on the
opposite side kind of yet kind of
distracting it cuz it all only occurs in
the finale and that yeah there are
themes like that throughout the movie
that are handled really well and then
the finale as a whole I feel like the
climax of this movie is kind of early as
compared to where the story of the film
has to end yeah the whole question is
are they gonna print this stuff is it
gonna get to the people or not and there
are some other things I have to wrap up
after that question finally is seen
through it's that stuff that kind of
feels like okay we don't need to spend a
lot of time on this but it's all
wrapping up pretty quick and it's all
very neat and the writing is more neat
now and everything feels a little more
shiny now yeah you know cuz there's a
moment where when they all get the word
from the court that the press is free
there's a woman on the phone who these
cameras panning in on she's like quoting
the government saying it seems like
they're really try get this across and
the final scene which is a real nice
moment cuz there's nice moments in here
where Meryl Streep is down where they're
printing the papers and Tom Hanks shows
up and then she's like you know what I
think we can do as the press and here's
what we could do moving forward it
seemed like such a message that she was
delivering to the audience she might as
well have said that to the camera forgot
the actual ending of the movie cuz I
thought this movie should have ended on
that seen the actual ah yeah when it's
like Watergate sequel set up which I
know it's not doing I felt like it was
like why is this an MCU movie now what's
going on see that's another moment that
I I guess I'm kind of torn on cuz half
of me is like oh that's a cool bookend
you know but the other half yeah kind of
left me with the feeling of are they
gonna come back next summer
yeah will the Washington Post returns
they just feel like it's out of a
different movie even
style of it felt like a different type
of political thriller in that moment it
weirdly feels like a sequel set up when
I know it's not but it feels like that
and I thought it wasn't necessary
because it is such an easter egg ending
it is such a buddy who knows history
they're gonna load this [ __ ] it's just
like if everyone knows comic books
you're gonna love this scene you know I
think it's bad to have included it I
just again it's I would have handled and
it's a way to handle like I actually
really like it as a choice like to be
like oh here's what's coming next in in
the history of the world Oh cinematic
shoot yeah American history cinematic
universe I felt like this movie is about
Tom Hanks and Meryl Streep and their
journey was done so ended there that's
just pretty much how I felt oh it's
called the post do you know you should
have just made a post-credits scene it's
called the post that's it feels like it
feels like security credits are supposed
to play there but you know that less
people were going to stay through the
growth yeah see if there's anything
there should be a postcard at scene for
the post
and that would be perfect for that
because it's cold because then it would
be then it would be yeah I'm trying to
say the whole hi alright guys well in
the end of it all I would give this
movie a solid 4.5 out of 5 stars I think
it's well acted it's well executed its
powerful in a lot of ways and it's
surprisingly really intense overall it
might settle it like a four for me but
because it surprised me and it gripped
me a lot more than I thought it wouldn't
I appreciate it so much more I'll go at
like a four and a half with you I'll
join you there or I reject nation well
thanks for tuning in what did you think
of the post is it spill Berg's best
movie since Indiana Jones and the Temple
of the Lost Ark comment below guys you
can subscribe to the reel rejects click
that notification bell again notified
every time one of our videos is up and
download this Stardust app and follow us
first special link in the description
box and last but not least over at our
patreon we started doing television show
reactions and music videos because
full-length TV show and full-length
music videos often get blocked on
YouTube but go become a patron ejected a
support the channel and check out some
awesome new content
and high PD